It is a field of mathematics with very ancient roots,
whose objective, put simply,
is to study the evolution in the very long term...
of a system whose evolution in the short term may be given by a simple rule,
but in which even simple short-term rules can cause big issues in the long term.
One very commonly cited example (because people are very familiar with it),
and which was initially defined in the 17th century,
is a planetary system ruled by Newton's gravitational rules.
It doesn't need much more complication to become interesting.
If you have two masses interacting,
you will have what people know as the behavior of elliptical orbits,
which are well known, are regular and persist in time.
But there is a question that has been asked since then,
and which is still not well understood:
If you have 3 systems interacting through the same gravitation laws for the short-term,
which are well defined and understood for a long time now,
what can you say about behavior in the very long term?
This is what interests Mathematicians looking at this system:
If you ignore other limitations,
like a sun exploding or imploding, or something similar,
or other things that may happen in the timescales we can consider,
then, in a potentially limitless timescale ruled only by gravitational rules,
one would like to be able to make interesting conclusions.
Would these planets, which seem to propagate regularly,
start interacting in more complicated ways and escape far beyond where they began?
Thing like this.
That is one example of a question that can be asked,
and there are many other systems.
We can start from modeling,
such as a model with population interactions,
with several populations competing over simple rules,
and try to predict what could happen with the system.
Maybe you want to know what would happen if you made a small intervention in it.
Would it be catastrophic, or potentially catastrophic?
Another thing that is understood…
There are also systems based on purely theoretical models,
used only to explore abstract approaches to dynamic systems,
or sometimes interactions with other fields of Math, like numbers theory...
and a few abstract dynamic systems that don't model physical phenomena,
but only mathematical ones that answer interesting questions...
that don't initially seem to be about dynamic systems.
But what interests people when we talk about...
the potential to say something interesting on long-term behavior,
one major finding from discoveries made along the last century...
is the discovery of the frequency and inevitability of chaotic behaviors.
These are systems in which chaos appears - which may happen even with simple rules -
despite these simple rules, and in certain scenarios,
it is often theoretically impossible to make very...
accurate predictions of what behavior will be at any given time.
In this case, some questions would be hard to answer:
if I have this system, and, say, look at it a million years from now,
at that moment, what would the state of that system be?
Imagine we are measuring something in a physical system,
like the temperature of something, which is evolving, and ask:
What will temperature be at a very precise moment in the very distant future?
That is often a question that one, when faced with chaos,
can't reasonably give intelligent answers to.
On the other hand, you can ask more statistical questions about the system,
which is also something that has been developed.
The idea is, even faced with this unpredictability,
which indeed arises...
in things like the so-called 'butterfly effect', where even small changes...
create changes so large they prevent predictions,
sometimes it is possible to robustly describe not the exact, precise behavior at point X,
but rather 'average behaviors'.
Something like being able to say 'in period X,
average temperature will likely be about Y'.
This is somewhat related to the robustness of statistical laws.
It can be compared to...
a situation in which you are playing a game of heads and tails.
The question of what the next toss will be...
is not one you can say much about.
It's either heads or tails, 50/50.
So you can't predict accurately.
But you can say, quite confidently
that if you do 1,000 tosses, you will have approximately 500 heads and 500 tails,
with error margins that can be well estimated.
You'll have said something useful about the behavior as a whole,
but not about a single toss.
What happens with chaotic systems is interesting...
Heads/tails tosses have inherent randomness.
But sometimes you start with a system deterministic in principle,
but whose intrinsic complications create behavior close to randomness.
And, in fact, the best way to model this behavior, even though it is deterministic,
is through a law that assumes the system is truly random.
It can be approximated quite well by a system very similar to coin tossing.
That allows you to say interesting things in the same way...
about this system's average behavior.
That's an example of a question, and answers, and type of answer...
modern dynamic systems theory can offer when chaos is involved.
I have worked on several aspects of dynamic systems.
I didn't work only on chaotic systems, that was more a general example.
I often work with systems that have a little less chaos in them,
and one of the methods I used the most often...
in different scenarios is the one known as renormalization.
The concept has a certain history,
and represents different things in different areas.
It means one thing in Physics, another in Dynamic Systems,
and maybe others for other fields of Math.
For Dynamic Systems specifically, it is used to try to understand the behavior...
of a system in a certain 'subarea'.
The system acts over a certain space of configurations,
and you would like to focus attention on behavior in a small subset of that space,
but, as usual, over a very long time horizon.
So you obtain a certain system with this new time and space scale,
which you then re-scale - you renormalize -
and imagine your whole time horizon is in fact just one time beat,
and that subarea is in fact your whole space, that it corresponds to the whole.
In certain situations, the system you obtain through this process...
is qualitatively similar to the one you started with,
even though it is not exactly the same.
In these cases, you will find a sort of operation in the space of dynamic systems...
that has certain specific features.
This change of scale on how you observe systems,
going to a smaller space and longer time scale,
leads from one dynamic system to another, but within the same 'class'.
This idea, surprisingly, works quite well...
in certain classes of systems that are not chaotic.
When you consider a chaotic system and change its time scale,
you produce something with much more chaos.
Information loss becomes much faster with a longer time scale.
But for other systems that are more regular than a completely chaotic one,
you have this potential - not always, but in some situations -
of arriving at a system not so different, qualitatively, from what you had before.
Then, as you try to study and achieve longer and deeper time scales for your system,
You begin trying to iterate this process,
and making that operation in the dynamic systems space.
In general, you consider this acting over systems in small dimensional scales.
These are 1- or 2-dimensional spaces - we live in a 3-dimensional one,
but many interesting dynamic systems happen in low-dimensional spaces,
on a plane or on a straight line.
So if you consider these systems,
and look at this action in the space of the systems,
you're looking at them in space that is often of infinite dimensions
What we are studying here, then,
is this operation in a class of systems that live in an infinite-dimension space.
And, interestingly, when a system operates over itself,
you can repeat it - and you are interested in repeating it.
You get a new dynamic system, with a new set of features,
that now acts, that 'lives', in a much bigger space.
What is surprising is that now you're in something much more complicated,
- from, say, one dimension to infinite dimensions -
but it is frequently possible to say very interesting things...
about this infinite-dimension system.
And this repeats often, for several situations...
when we discover this infinite-dimension system now has chaotic features.
And then the methods that are efficient to analyze certain chaotic systems,
including this probabilistic analysis I mentioned,
can be used to later say interesting things...
about the low-dimension system we were interested in at first.
This sort of idea emerged in the 1970s,
and was well developed in several directions in the next decades.
I applied them several times in my work,
on studies of one-dimensional systems, for example,
or certain scenarios on the behavior of billiards,
which is also something I worked on...
and also on certain aspects of certain Schrodinger operators,
which are also modeled on dynamic systems that frequently can also be renormalized.
It's an idea that has been developing for a while.
I applied and developed certain techniques, and incorporated...
For every scenario in which you use this group of ideas,
some features differ,
and you have to integrate them to understand things.
I began working in the low-dimension dynamics of the interval.
These are very well developed applications, associated with some well-known fractals,
such as the Mandelbrot Set and the like.
But then, over time, I became interested in other systems...
that could also be subject to renormalization theories.
You have to understand how these ideas can be applied,
because the questions that it can help answer are different.
For instance, when I began my work on Schrodinger operators,
it was interesting to me how the questions were asked differently.
The ultimate goal wasn't even to understand a given dynamic system.
The system was the means to analyze the associated equation's behavior...
which will correspond to a dynamic, now a non-classical one.
Before, I was talking of classical dynamics, with deterministic laws.
But when I was interested in Schrödinger operators,
the goal was to understand a quantum dynamics phenomenon,
but before arriving at the equation that will say interesting things about it,
you have the option to use this classical dynamic system model...
to understand a piece of the equation.
Actually you have to understand a family of dynamic systems...
associated with the various possible energies for your quantum system.
For each energy there is a different classical system that you can look at...
and will yield a good behavior of that system's functions.
The issue is you need...
I had a long learning process to discover what interested people.
I began with dynamic systems,
but people had specific questions to ask about these operators,
and on what understanding of the dynamics would allow you...
to reach any conclusions on the aspects of that equation at the end.
Renormalization, then, was one part of a theory, but I branched out later.
I started by using it, it was sort of the way I started.
When I began, this was in 2002, 2003, and I realized...
renormalization could be used to better understand some specific problems.
Later, this started yielding interesting results,
such as conclusions about the fractal known as the Hofstadter's butterfly,
merely by using renormalization slightly differently from how it was used before.
Then I went on to other aspects less related to normalization,
which could, after a long time,
be reunified with renormalization for a deeper understanding of the area.
But this took many years.
I still work on it, but there was slow progress for many years…
Then in 2008-09,
I had a better understanding of how to unify these aspects,
including by looking at another area that is also very present in my work:
the Lyapunov exponents.
Specifically, understanding the appearance of 0 or positive Lyapunov exponents.
Lyapunov exponents are certain numbers associated to a dynamic system...
which detect a bit of the instability of the system.
What is the speed at which orbits separate, for instance?
You begin with two configurations, two orbits that are quite close,
and they begin separating at a certain exponential speed,
which is the rapid loss associated with chaotic systems.
I usually work with many potential problems.
I work on one at a given moment,
but I oscillate a lot over a few days or weeks...
thinking in different directions.
What often happens in this work...
is that you arrive at an obstacle where you lack...
ideas on how you can move forward or what the strategy is.
In that scenario...
where will the idea come from that will allow you to 'unblock',
and continue the work on a more…
objective, actually...
in a more comprehensible way?
Once you have an idea to work with,
there are several techniques that can be used,
and many ways to find associations and move ahead towards a solution.
But without a starting point, that gets very hard.
There isn't much to do.
You know that, with current ideas and techniques,
you can't get past a certain point.
When you get to this 'blockage',
there is no formula on how to get out.
There are theories on how discovery happens,
and some say it happens in the subconscious,
and it is not something that can be 'willed' by the person,
but regardless of those, there are interesting possibilities to consider…
You get to a block, you try, and after a while it becomes clear...
you don't have what you need at that time.
Then maybe it is interesting to look at something else,
first psychologically, so you don't feel you're banging your head against a wall,
and also because, if you look into another direction,
you may end up having a new idea, or...
getting in touch with a new idea, without looking directly at the former direction,
and then a new idea can arise,
that you can see as useful to the problem you were working on before.
This happened with me sometimes.
I was working with multiple problems,
and realized what I was working on in a certain context...
helped open the path for progress in another context.
It could give me some…
Sometimes it's just a different perspective on something.
You basically had all elements,
but you needed the right angle to pick the right way to move forward.
That depends a lot on the situation.
Each project has its own traits.
The choice of working entirely without using paper or the like...
is a bit deliberate in some situations,
to try to avoid the temptation of going for a more 'brute force' approach,
more calculation-heavy approach to systems.
I avoid calculating very complicated things,
and if you don't have paper around you,
it limits what you can calculate.
So, instead of calculating,
you need to understand what you are studying better...
until the moment the calculation you need becomes evident.
It becomes so simple that you can do it in your head.
You try to increase your understanding in a more abstract way,
and see how this can be interpreted differently.
More obvious things, like expressions etc.,
can be manipulated so you can look at how they can interact differently.
It is a choice I make,
because I think it tends to be very fruitful.
I think there is a lot that can be done in terms of calculations,
but I usually work in collaboration,
and other people can do the calculations, and sometimes they don't get there.
So I prefer to think a bit of what can be done without calculations,
and sometimes it can merge with the calculation work some of my colleagues did.
I don't really look…
In the situations in which I am working out of the office,
and indeed I do,
either walking, or on the beach…
The goal is not for me to be inspired by my environment.
What is important is that it is a calm environment,
and you can be without a clear distraction.
Interestingly, for instance,
the sound of the ocean will not lead to...
will not cause great distraction, because it is constant.
If you had people screaming around, thing would be more complicated.
You usually want an environment where you do not worry about what is around you.
There may be the occasional distraction,
but mostly you want to have calm periods.
And, at that moment,
what you think depends on the situation.
On the beach, for instance,
I have worked many times trying to refine...
This was work on random matrix multiplications,
which can be seen as dynamic systems.
And the analysis technique I thought could be appropriate...
involved the understanding of certain geometries, or configurations,
on planes of high dimensional complexity,
the different interactions between them..
how they evolve with the application of certain linear transformations.
So I basically imagined positions for various objects in these spaces,
and how they would be changed by the transformations,
and how these changes could be...
'domesticated' by the technique we were thinking of using.
You had to build certain objects, in the case certain expressions,
which would adapt to possible configurations, and which would evolve...
in a certain direction that would be beneficial to us,
influenced by a certain dynamics - a chaotic one, in this case.
So I did that…
I imagined the types of configuration that were of concern for this technique,
and how I could...
modify the expressions to take this new scenario into account.
And I insisted on doing that without paper,
because it wouldn't be useful for that.
I needed a good understanding of the nature of the obstacle.
In this particular case,
it took a long time to overcome this problem.
Many tries, and conversations with colleagues...
In other situations,
it can be simply a matter of reconsidering something you thought of many times...
and still have no way forward,
and then try again after a while.
Like I said, not always focusing on the problem you don't get,
but it might be worth revisiting later.
Maybe an idea will come out from something else that has matured.
So you try again.
In general you realize that you are still stuck,
but you keep trying, and sometimes a solution comes out.
So you walk, and think again of the problem you were stuck on before,
reflect, understand once more why you couldn't do it…
This last time I went to the beach, for instance,
I was thinking of a problem that often comes to my mind,
and which I always find the same difficulties with.
But I come back to it in the hope I will see something different.
In general, mathematical knowledge...
often ends up being applied to scientific developments,
like in Physics or Chemistry,
and eventually in technological progress.
I would say that, in our current world,
it is quite obvious to see how past Mathematics...
was important for us to have the resources we take for granted today.
So we can imagine the breakthroughs that we achieve in Math today...
will have future repercussions,
even though it is impossible to predict how this will happen,
and what breakthroughs will have the biggest repercussions.
Of course, there is Mathematics that is done...
with clearer goals for immediate application.
You can do research with consequences that are...
immediately calculable for certain technologies…
Certain advances, for instance, in Medicine,
such as techniques in tomography and the like,
are based on research that requires very targeted Mathematical breakthroughs.
That said, I don't think all contributions of a study...
have a direct application in possible technologies.
I would imagine that there is a society of Mathematicians and scientists who interact,
and their ideas interact, and the questions and answers...
of persons working on different things end up reverberating.
So, even if one sees Math...
as a concern merely for its more visible impact on society
- which is not necessarily mine - but even from that standpoint,
the study of a broad spectrum of Mathematics,
going from the purer side to the more applicability-driven side…
It is all part of...
It all interacts in the end. All these ideas interact.
A researcher who studies something more esoteric,
which sometimes seems foolish to observers from the outside…
About objects that look like a game Mathematicians play with themselves…
These studies will often unexpectedly raise questions and techniques...
that slowly propagate to other areas of Mathematics often identified as important,
and sometimes end up being precisely...
what someone with a 'clearer' goal needed.
These ideas go in these directions, and the opposite direction as well.
Many fundamental concepts of interest to Mathematicians who want to "play around",
the 'purer' Mathematicians,
who are more concerned with abstractions, the so-called 'aesthetics of Mathematics',
who want to understand a thing very intrinsically to that thing,
without concern for the outside world,
will also find questions and techniques from research done with clearer goals.
Ideas will go from one side to the other, and vice-versa.
So, an environment where all this research happens concurrently...
is much more productive than if you only had one focus,
and could only look at it in terms of how it can lead you...
to a certain goal within a certain time frame.
I believe many discoveries wouldn't have been made, and won't be made,
without an environment that can drive...
this work in all of these directions at the same time.
So this would be...
I am more concerned with...
I am happy that people are using my work,
but I am more concerned with solving problems that in fact interest me...
and which will interest me due to what I have studied and have been thinking.
This creates a certain 'taste' for Mathematics,
and a trend to try to seek a better understanding of certain parts of Math.
A willingness to understanding something that is often focused on specific issues.
And, in Math, having this understanding often requires solving very specific problems...
that identify the main difficulties associated with that understanding.
Many times, however, you don't work on responding questions asked of you.
Many interesting questions you ask yourself.
It has happened, and sometimes happens,
that as you learn more about a topic,
you see the question as something different from what other people see.
Each one has their own view,
and sees a certain field of Math with their own internal representation,
which is influenced by past experience and knowledge.
Each Mathematician brings their contribution.
I bring mine, which comes from an intercession of many prior things.
In certain circumstances, this position can be particular and special in a certain field,
and that allows me to offer questions and approaches…
that wouldn't have been natural for other people in that area.
This certainly has happened quite clearly...
in my study of Schrodinger operators, or a certain class of them.
I had the ability to pose questions and propose approaches,
and ended up doing a little bit of everything.
I proposed questions that were not natural, but which, when posed,
made it clear that they were essential, and that were needed for progress.
I try to propose questions,
but associated with a possible way to understand it,
with context so that it can be developed.
And then, using my technical characteristics and my individual knowledge,
take that research to its end and find the solution to all this,
leading to a somewhat developed theory...
that will answer the questions that were asked.
Then, when these techniques are developed, they can be used elsewhere,
One would expect, then, that beautiful Mathematical techniques will be reused.
And they tend to - and I find this natural -
become knowledge incorporated by others,
who can use it in varied situations.
It is desirable that this is the natural path of discovery in this field.
I try…
I think people say this more because of my work style.
In a few of the topics I studied, I came sort of from the 'outside'.
I wrote my thesis on a certain field, and when I arrived in Paris,
I found few people who wanted to talk to me about what I was working on.
Then, so I wouldn't keep talking to myself, I wanted to learn what was being done.
But I didn't know a lot about what they were doing.
And when I looked at these fields,
I chose a somewhat…
unconventional approach.
Acceptable, of course, but an unconventional approach to relatively complex things.
Instead of trying to start from the beginning, with simpler questions,
I tried looking at things I would consider important,
but that would tell me something from the point of view I was coming from.
I worked many times with very little understanding of the state of theory,
at least at that time,
and decided to try to look at them with my little knowledge of that particular area,
and see what that tells me.
Sort of thinking from scratch.
This led to certain approaches that were not being used in these areas,
and sometimes, due certainly to some luck and some work,
led to solutions for problems that were somewhat stalled,
that weren't seeing progress in that direction.
That may be why people say that,
because I decided to look at things from a different perspective,
mostly because I didn't know how people were looking at it,
and didn't try too much.
For a while now, I've had this trend of not studying the works of others so much.
I know what has been done, but my main strategy is not to read it in depth.
I try to find out what ideas are in vogue,
but without trying to understand the literature exhaustively.
I get an idea of the fundamental issues,
and try to think of something different that can help to advance these.
I think I would have less to contribute...
if I tried to improve a little on techniques people are already trying to apply.
I think I have a better chance to contribute...
by reflecting on what is not being done,
and on what would be natural for someone not deeply involved in an given area.
I suspect that is what people alluded to when they told you this.
Well, Math...
When you are a child,
you are not really presented to what really is a Mathematical work.
You are introduced to a few numbers first, like I did as a child,
and that they have their characteristics, and some internal logic.
There are a few things that are true and remain true, that don't evolve,
just like other areas of knowledge.
Certain somewhat primitive aspects of Mathematics,
which were all I know,
looked interesting from the start.
It was a very fortuitous thing for my knowledge,
that I really liked to read very basic things about Math, school Math,
that were quite rudimentary,
and I 'didn't dislike' that aspect.
Then I became interested in Math Olympiads, solving Olympiad problems.
And I found those a lot of fun, too. Studying those problems.
And then I started working on more theoretical areas, when I did my Master's,
I had to learn more, which I also found interesting.
This more abstract learning.
And then I started doing research,
with the characteristics I described just now.
And it was interesting.
Throughout those phases, it was possible…
For instance, it's perfectly normal for a great researcher to hate Olympiad problems,
or hate this aspect.
That is perfectly possible.
In my case, in all my life progress until I became a researcher,
maybe because of my story growing up,
it looked very interesting at that time.
Afterwards I lost interest in Math Olympiad problems, for instance,
it doesn't entice me today, but it was important to me at that time.
It is curious that at each moment something interested me,
and allowed me to progress a little bit faster.
There was no moment of "I'm not interested in Mathematics anymore".
"I have lost interest in this area. I don't want this."
This could have make me drift away,
but at each moment I found something interesting,
until I became a researcher, and have had the same interest since then...
to discover new Mathematics and understand certain aspects better,
which is what interests me now.
It's a feature of...
Well, it is an award conceived at a certain time,
and its story is well-known.
The idea was to have an international award, which didn't exist at the time...
It was the first one.
And its message was to convey unity of the Mathematics community.
It would be given by the International Mathematics Congress, in principle open to all,
at a time when there was some…
It was between the two World Wars,
and there were problems with nationalism and things of the sort.
So there are historical reasons for how it was introduced.
The creator of the award, called Fields,
wanted it to be an award given to young people, younger than 40.
It was not meant as an "end-of-career" award to celebrate a body of work,
but rather to highlight promising work, sometimes well fleshed out,
by someone who is active and likely to continue working.
It has characteristics that differ it from a Nobel Prize,
which is usually given as a reward at the end of a career.
I think there are certain positive aspects…
I don't think…
It is not a good inspiration to do good Mathematics,
or good science, or anything,
to seek to obtain some award for it.
I think it is the wrong direction to look,
even because many things are discovered by looking at less promising directions.
By looking at what really interests you, even though it may not interest others,
you end up discovering something that becomes and is seen as fundamental.
It is important that people look at all directions.
If we all look at the direction that looks more likely to be rewarded,
we will have very biased perspectives, and things won't develop as well.
Also, you do better Mathematics if you do something that genuinely interests you.
That is the real motivation.
That, and it is not a very reasonable goal...
to work in depth aiming at something so rare to achieve.
Not many awards like this are given,
they are like a Nobel or the like...
It is interesting that it has an effect...
There is this negative effect,
in that people, when they feel it's possible for them to win this award,
to try to win this award while they can, i.e. under 40,
so, in fact, it is hard to deny that it creates some competition,
but the positive side is that it has an expiration date.
After all, these awards are given, and then fulfill their role.
And for me, their role, be they the Nobel, Fields, and others that are well known,
is to communicate with the public.
It is through these awards that people see progress is being made in science.
So, when people talk…
There is this week of the year when the Nobels are given out,
and people will talk about advances in Medicine, Physics, Chemistry etc.
And this is interesting.
It lets people know that this work is being done,
and how important it is, and that it continues to be done.
So there is this aspect of bringing science closer...
to a community that won't hear this constantly.
That is the main point, I imagine,
the most important contribution of these awards.
Also, like I said,
they have this negative potential to generate harmful competition sometimes.
So the advantage of the Fields medal, in comparison with other career awards,
is that it has a deadline.
When you get to 40 you no longer need to worry about it, regardless of the result.
It fulfills its role, and doesn't have as much of the harmful effect...
in terms of making people continuously obsessed with this goal.
Yes, but I also don't understand a lot of what is done by the community.
This is something you discover relatively quickly as a Mathematician:
the depth and enormous number of different directions people research.
You have characteristics, and preferences…
For instance, just to give you an idea:
I have a line of thought that leads me to approach....
issues of a general part of Mathematics known as Analysis.
There are estimates,
and you try to obtain notions of physical quantities,
of how large or small things are, relationships, interactions…
But there is some more flexibility.
Other aspects, which I'd call more algebraic,
have rigid equations, manipulated precisely,
that give exact answers all the time...
This is home to another type of thinking, that I find more rigid.
My intuition goes more to the former than the latter,
so I have difficulty trying to understand those,
even things that are not so complicated.
Certainly for the latest advances in these areas,
I lack the framework to be able to say much about them.
So for me it is quite natural that advances that are,
like you said, on the "frontier" of knowledge,
are not accessible to people not working on them.
Yet, aspects...
A few aspects of discoveries end up being gradually conveyed.
This is one of the ideas I put forward.
Some Mathematicians work between two areas,
and they often 'transfer' these ideas.
This communication happens.
Sometimes it needs to go through several Mathematicians to go from here to there,
but it has this potential.
I did that in some directions,
bring some ideas from one subarea of dynamic systems to another,
and this is also done by people working with me in other directions.
I would consider it natural to see this difficulty of communication.
It is part of the complexity of the things we work with,
but at the same time I don't worry much that they will be isolated eternally.
They continue having the potential to influence others...
who may not understand exactly what I do, but can be influenced by a certain path...
by a few ideas developed in this area.
I don't think much in terms of predicting, because if I look back,
I realize I didn't envisage 10 years ago what I am doing now.
I had some idea, but it was basically...
'I'll probably be interested in things that interest me today,
but will certainly be interested in others I cannot predict now'.
For me it is very natural, working with dynamic systems,
to be unable to make such accurate predictions.
It doesn't worry me much not being able to predict as much.
In a more abstract level, or at a different level,
one goal would be to try to maintain the general characteristics…
In Mathematics it is easier.
In other sciences you work close to the technique, and production is direct.
Then you gain managerial responsibilities,
and have to manage other people and their work more than your own.
In Math that doesn't happen often.
You have small teams,
and Mathematicians, as much as they progress,
often tend to work as close to the 'base' as they did when they began.
So my wish, which is not hard to fulfill,
is to continue to work directly 'hands on'.
I am glad that Math is like this.
It would upset me if the consequence of doing good work...
was to be pushed to direct the work of others,
instead of having the pleasure to continuing to make discoveries directly.
It is interesting to think of Mathematics…
Mathematics… often...
Many who did not pursue more knowledge...
often don't know how Mathematicians think of mathematical objects.
Naturally, each will think differently,
but I believe some things are relatively general.
You are not working only with equations and numbers.
There is meaning and there is representation,
basically corresponding to mathematical objects.
These mathematical objects...
They are abstract, they don't have tangible reality,
so each Mathematician has their own interpretation, sees them differently.
Maybe visual, maybe not describable in terms corresponding to senses,
but there is an inner interpretation of that.
And the one creates...
Imagine Mathematics as populated by objects with connections between them,
and with aspects revealed when seen in a certain way.
You have a notion of a rich Mathematical theory,
with connections that appear quite surprisingly,
sometimes between things that did not appear to be related.
And these connections, these intersections...
of many subjects that end up being discovered as you study certain objects,
contribute to this view that they have...
We call it "richness".
And there's an appreciation of this order, this organization…
that takes place.
In general, this is what, for many are people,
tends to lead to a sensation called 'aesthetic appreciation',
and to call these types of objects 'beautiful'.
That is basically it.
This beauty is seen very subjectively by each Mathematician,
and communicated between them.
There is this attempt to communicate, which is interesting.
They have their personal view of objects,
but manage to convey them in a way.
It is imprecise, since you don't convey it totally,
but you do convey a few aspects that enrich the understanding by the other.
But it is sill very individual, how one interprets each universe.
Mathematics always seemed to me to be something...
let's say 'stable',
and which always develops.
The more you learn, the more you find that you ignore as it develops.
Our breakthroughs are much slower...
than the pace of discovery of what we don't know.
On the other hand,
what you can achieve...
becomes part, albeit small, of a growing theory…
And this fact that mathematical knowledge accumulates,
that it is not destructive in its nature…
like can happen in other areas of knowledge,
where theories overlap, or contradict each other at certain times,
or develop, and become obsolete,
and are fully replaced over time.
Mathematical knowledge develops,
but does not invalidate what has been discovered in the past.
There may be more complicated developments,
but it persists quite well.
This is one thing that has always attracted me, and given me some…
I like to think of Math at a moment of tranquility,
and even when I am not in that state to bring some of it,
to think of it as something that 'is there',
that has its characteristics, that has its logic.
It may be difficult sometimes, and it may seem very rigid,
and make you work hard to do things that seem so evident,
but that same work, those same rules,
lead to the fact that when you reach a goal, it is stable.
It has structure.
And that is not something easily found elsewhere.
That is something pleasant to think about.
Maybe at more tense moments,
if you need to separate from anything that may be drawing your attention,
if you manage it, you can be in the mathematical world again,
with its rules, and its stability.
So, it has its moments,
but I wouldn't...
I would say that, emotionally, that has a small role in that sense.
Afraid… I guess I'm not afraid.
You have to be realistic about what you can discover,
and how things happen…
You don't need to...
I don't see it as very problematic when you have moments...
in which it looks like you are not making progress.
That is normal in any long career.
Any mathematician will go through this,
and experiences teaches you that many things depend on...
being at the right moment and having a bit of luck as well.
These oscillations happen.
This type of concern doesn't affect me much.
I think you have to persist in seeking things,
be realistic about the fact that most times you won't get to where you would like to,
remain determined, and appreciate when things work.
In daily work in Math,
most of the time you are working with things you know well,
and developing techniques that you already master,
seeking to take them a bit further.
Most often, this work...
is what is more visible as 'work'.
Like I said, you are often stuck without an idea,
and you wait for this 'unblock'.
So, sometimes it appears you're doing nothing,
then a short moment when you realize something that can make a difference,
and then the more 'conventional' work,
which involves a lot of creativity, but when it's easier to understand what is needed.
It is more 'concrete', perceivable work.
This moment of discovery,
when you feel you understood something different,
is an interesting one emotionally.
It combines several things.
You often get the immediate feeling that it can be important,
but sometimes that's inaccurate.
You become immediately excited about the potential,
of what can unfold from that idea.
You really want it to be fruitful,
and sometimes cling to keeping it alive in the face of difficulties.
At the same time, there are doubts,
and it is part of a Mathematician's work...
to attack your own ideas to find possible faults.
It's an emotionally complicated approach. There are several sides of you.
One side wants the idea to work,
but you have to work on finding the faults in it,
and of course would like not to,
but it is very productive to put a lot of energy into it,
so you're not working with an idea that turns out to be problematic.
Sometimes these moments are complicated…
But this excitement happens at very precise times,
and in general is what precedes this more arduous work.
You need to think about it, but have the feeling something can happen.
I don't believe much...
I don't believe much in looking directly or continuously...
at a very complicated direction.
I think things happens more naturally.
I mentioned that sometimes you could be looking in a different direction...
and you get that 'click', you have an idea and think:
'This could finally be useful for that big problem you considered before'.
So I prefer not to look directly at the problems.
I have done it for some,
but I know of several problems in dynamic systems that are fundamental,
whose understanding and solution would lead to great progress...
in our general understanding of specific dynamic systems that interest me,
but I think it is very hard to predict where you will go,
so I avoid thinking in terms of 'I would really like to solve problem X'.
There are many problems that everybody would like to solve,
but it is not something I define as a major goal.
I find it interesting to talk about things that are non mathematical...
with non-Mathematicians and mathematicians as well.
There are many topics that are interesting…
I don't think I'd have a great need to discuss work with them.
When people can appreciate it, math is one more topic of conversation,
but it's perfectly reasonable for different people to have very different interests,
and I don't see the need to try to talk about these things…
It's natural not to be interested in them.
Well, I have solved many problems...
that resisted approaches for a long time, that is true.
This is a feature of the way I work.
And I like solving problems like that, and to formulate questions.
But I certainly am attracted to some questions not just because they were open,
even because there are so many them,
but some because they cover issues for which I've developed a certain 'affection'.
This brings self-satisfaction,
and it is nice to speak to other Mathematicians about them,
but is not something I need to discuss with everyone.
I don't need everyone to appreciate it.
The most fundamental appreciation for your work must be your own.
If you don't appreciate your own work, you'll have a lot of trouble pursuing it.
This is something you have to seek, and once you get it,
it is nice that your colleagues appreciate it too,
and to talk to them about it,
to have this exchange and hear from them,
but it is a part of it…
I have no need for everyone to appreciate my contributions.
No…
I always work a lot with others, and find people I can talk to.
In some of the work there was a gap...
between the needs to make it progress and what others could contribute,
even because it took many simultaneous traits and I was more suitable to do it alone,
but as time goes by, if you work is interesting,
it's normal for people to follow and investigate how they can use it,
or even improve what we had.
I don't have this feeling...
Mathematicians, they have…
There is that contribution that leads to solutions to problems,
but that often comes from work that didn't bring solutions but introduced ideas,
so I am aware of and greatly appreciate this work that is done,
and is often overlooked by awards etc.,
but that is fundamental for the progress of Math.
So I see the contributions of all who worked in this field.
Each of them did something that, if they hadn't,
I wouldn't have done anything or have a field to work on.
I also know that,
even when something I do has technical difficulties...
that means it may take a while to be appreciated,
I do hope it is, and that it will be useful to people.
That it's not something that stays isolated in me,
but that increases the overall mathematical knowledge of the community.
So there's that.
It's not just…
I would be reasonably satisfied to have my own fulfillment...
for having gotten somewhere on a problem whose solution interests me,
but there's this additional component, and I don't particularly feel it is missing.
Between mathematical thought and everyday life?
In that sense?
Depends on the type of problem you're working on.
There are certain situations in which...
you do these internal representations of the object,
and try to look at them differently.
It could be by seeking a side you haven't explored yet but could develop,
or it could be manipulations,
where it is clear, or you have identified something that can lead to a solution,
but which has some internal complexities.
Then you do something close to - albeit quite different -
from what non-Mathematicians call 'calculation',
and then do approximations that we Mathematicians would also 'calculate',
to estimate the consequences of certain processes.
You do certain procedures to manipulate objects,
and see if that reveals any other traits to be explored.
In that process, you are indeed doing a sequence of operations,
and imagining which next operation can be useful,
and all that happens inside your head…
Hard to describe further than that.
And that also varies in each situation.
It is possible to get distracted in a few situations.
Not sure if much more than other people,
but I do have this tendency, when I start thinking of something,
to become somewhat involved.
I think certain activities require some level of exclusive dedication,
especially if it creates certain risks to yourself or to other people,
such as driving.
And I would imagine that there is a trend...
to get comfortable with anything that becomes repetitive,
and in which you develop a feeling of safety.
And that could lead you to think of other things,
initially lightly, but then draw a lot of your attention inadvertently.
That may not cause any consequences, maybe out of luck,
but you are creating the possibility that it will.
There is also the issue that I prefer to live in urban areas...
where the need to have your own car is reduced.
I don't make sacrifices by not driving while living in Rio or in Paris,
while in other cities of the world that could be an issue.
I don't feel this is a problem with my life here, though,
so I think it's not worth risking this,
or not risking it and having to force myself to fully dedicate...
to a relatively repetitive activity feeling like I can't distract from it.
I don't see the need for that.
I think it is easier to answer how I see…
why Math is something interesting to develop,
or why people should study it.
One of the reasons, which I mentioned,
has to do with repercussions and developments...
of technological progress and science in general through Math,
but Math, specially seen from the 'purer' side of it,
is often developed as something close to a form of...
artistic expression.
Maybe it is something that attracts fewer people than music or sculpture,
because understanding Math requires, even for its simpler concepts,
a certain immersion in a prior study that other artistic expressions...
don't require for you to immediately see why it is beautiful or moving.
But, with some preparation and dedication,
it can have the same potential impact.
Like I said, you can appreciate this, this order,
this increasing structuring, and the surprises that appear,
and things that are very similar or very different when you don't expect them to be,
and all these characteristics are...
something that many people can (and do) seek...
to advance in this...
advance in this search for abstract understanding,
and the formation of a mathematical universe.
You are building, or helping to build, this piece…
Maybe not a piece, but this knowledge of this interconnected mathematical universe...
that each one only knows a small part of, but can contribute to.
I see it as quite a natural thing, then,
that it attracts people.
Not all people, since each will be attracted to something different.
But it can be just as attractive, and is, to certain people,
as other completely natural forms of expression.
Math has a history that goes back to…
even before then, but recognizably to the ancient Greeks,
who often sought to learn Math or develop it...
because they considered it something natural to pursue.
As part of the human quest.
It's been like that since the beginning,
and it is important to emphasize that additional importance:
that, in addition to these more perceivable, tangible repercussions,
we should remember that it is more than that.
It incorporates other things that should be appreciated in a more intrinsic manner.
In Math, I see it as you...
finding out more about things that are well-established discoveries.
Of course, people make mistakes.
It is part of the process.
Any person can make mistakes, which may be short-lived,
but other than these errors - and those are often quite limited -
the mathematical knowledge being developed is considered in general to be true.
There is no serious dispute between mathematicians with different interpretations...
regarding the true nature of the status of a certain discovery made.
Mathematics is populated by small truths that correspond to a growing universe,
and so there is no great doubt when one is working.
It is something quite characteristic of our knowledge.
There have been moments of discussions in that sense,
the Mathematicians...
about the foundational issues of Math, including in dialogue with Philosophers...
but we have arrived at notions of the limitations, of where Math can take us.
Ambitions of total formalism have been somewhat abandoned.
The known limitations coming from Logic, coming from Gödel, for instance,
may have destroyed the more exaggerated ambitions of the beginning of the century,
I mean the 20th century,
and are now well understood.
Mathematicians essentially accept the limitations of what they can work on.
They know these limitations.
But they seek to work on certain well-defined objects,
they have the continuous feeling of obtaining something true and permanent.
In simple terms, pure Mathematics is considered to be that which is investigated...
without the goal of achieving immediate application outside Math.
It may find application, and many times it does.
Things that initially belonged...
It is more a way of selecting your research objects and your intention in studying them.
Sometimes the type of Math is the same used in applied and pure Math,
sometimes the objects are the same.
This distinction is based on intent and this leads to some selection,
in that applied Math will work more on certain types of objects,
and pure Math on others.
In the end, you will potentially be using the same things.
If it is Math, the same tools are valid for one side or the other.
But there is this distinction on what you select and what goals you have:
Is your interest intrinsic to Math, or are you seeking direct application of it?
I put myself…
I am more interested in the 'intrinsic interest' side…
I sometimes work on problems directly inspired by physical models etc.,
but the reason I select it to work on is not its applicability,
but rather because the associated mathematical theory interests me,
due to the characteristics I mentioned, such as its richness, beauty etc.
At that moment…
When I'm reflecting on issues,
seeking another idea without a very well-defined plan,
and you're not...
You have some hope, but are just seeking a starting point,
that takes relatively little time…
It's like I said, I could be working on something else,
but back then I was working on a question I didn't have a clear path for,
and that occupies relatively little time.
Much more time is spent on mathematical work when...
you start with an idea you already had,
and trying to develop it, and use other techniques...
to make connections in a more predictable way.
This attempt to arrive more consciously at an idea...
without knowing where it will come from...
is something I spent less time on.
I look at it again and check if something has matured,
but in general you get to the conclusion you already had very quickly.
Then, either something appears,
or you realize your manipulations keep leading you back to the same place,
and that you're not getting any further.
I don't consider it very useful to keep persisting in this.
In this problem in particular, recently I've been ending up in the same place.
Even though I try small variations, they all take me to the same place.
When I realize this, I tend to abandon it for a bit longer.
But that is not a large part of my day.
There isn't a set rhythm…
Every day has its characteristics.
I will spare a moment among my daily tasks to think of Math,
but as part of my practical obligations and the like.
Since I don't have a lot of standing obligations…
Sometimes I will arrange to speak with a student or a colleague,
and that will occupy a specific part of my day.
The moment I spare to work alone is when I feel more available,
but that changes from day to day.
I don't have fixed times in my schedule.
I also collaborate a lot with people from other countries on-line,
so I need to adapt my schedule to time zones etc.
No need to follow a very precise routine.
That changes a lot, but yes,
for a while now I've had the habit of waking up late.
I usually wake up at around noon or later.
And… These are my hours.
Since I don't have the need to wake up in the morning, I don't,
but on the other hand, I go to sleep later.
Other than that…
I wake up and take care of a few practical things,
like eating, going to the gym…
I do my chores when it is most convenient.
And like I said, there are the things that are more 'identifiable' as work,
and in certain moments you may find yourself thinking…
It has to be at a clear-headed moment…
It's hard, at least for me, to say "I will book this time for abstract thinking."
I may schedule to speak to colleagues for this,
but when I'm alone, I will choose a moment in which I feel more serene,
and without other sources of stress that can divide my attention.
I wait for these moments to happen naturally.
I don't like...
I don't think that's necessary,
but I don't like to plan very carefully how things will happens,
because I end up wanting to change things at the last minute.
Every plan I make may not be ideal, and I'll be tempted to change them,
so I try not to plan too far in advance.
I have some difficulty organizing in that sense,
but fortunately my work allows me to keep doing it this way.
I could do it - and many Mathematicians do it without issue -
within a very well-established routine.
But I feel uncomfortable with very rigid things,
so this would likely have a psychological impact of making me feel restricted,
and would bother me.
It is not a prerequisite to do the type of discovery I do.
I think it is more because of the emotional perception than anything else.
I find it interesting that in Math...
we are very accepting of people who can contribute however they can,
and that we do not put much stock in social conventions or norms.
They exist, but they do not prevent a person from doing their work.
In certain professions, people who do not conform to norms,
such as dress or basic behavior codes,
won't have the chance to work in them.
In Math, there might be people who are isolated,
or who are not very proficient in talking to others,
but who are contributing in many ways.
In the end their work will be assessed for its content, for what it brings.
Since there are no interpretations,
you don't have the defend your arguments...
and compare with different arguments and interpretations.
Normally, in most works,
you have a theory being developed,
and it can be assessed despite the rhetorical skills of the person defending it.
Any other person can then see it,
if the material is prepared according to the usual standards,
and say 'Yes, this answers the question' or not regardless of the person's personality.
This is quite desirable, because it doesn't exclude people that could contribute.
You don't have to be eccentric, or have difficulties interacting,
or any other odd trait to do Math,
but we don't exclude people in that regard.
There are all sorts of people in Math.
It is a stereotype to think that the rule is to have odd people,
it's just that they are accepted.
They are included, and often contribute,
and all sorts of people can be represented.
It depends on what you are investigating about the world.
There is this difficulty of making predictions in certain time scales,
and the effect of chaos must be recognized.
On the other hand, there is great order,
for instance, simply in the capacity to express physical laws in mathematical terms.
It is not obvious why that is possible, even in principle.
The fact that this happens allows for short-term predictability.
There are simple rules that govern this behavior,
This is a form of order that has no reason to exist.
We take it for granted today...
that certain aspects of Physics will have this type of behavior,
but it is not at all obvious that it has to be that way.
This ensures us the possibility of living our every-day lives...
knowing that nothing completely unusual will happen from a moment to the other.
There is a certain awareness of that.
So it depends on the issue.
You have to recognize in which situations chaos will be predominant,
and in which order will prevail.
You don't have to worry much about...
the fact that tomorrow the Moon will be present in some way or another.
Maybe full moon, maybe new, but there is not much doubt it will be there.
But it is an aspect of order we incorporate.
As for the weather, however,
you need to be prepared for other things.
Work in dynamic systems leads you to suspect the possibility that chaos exists,
but it is important to appreciate that there exists a great order as well.
It all depends on what you are researching.